the swoon is real Antonio sabato jr. is  joining Chippendales come with me I  wasn't always this attractive remember  him in those Calvin's yeah we do too  that was back in 96 when he was just 24  now at 44 it's crazy how not much has  changed but the posing Pro needs some  pointers from these stripping vets we  gotta get you in uniform you know  because some collars and they all smile  on your face  okay two backstage jobs we want lint  roller and body oil  speaking of jobs Antonio has been eyeing  this gig for a while this is like a  moment cuz you know growing up knowing  about the show and now I'm part of it  for five weeks Antoniou goes Magic Mike  at the Rio all Suite Hotel and Casino in  Las Vegas so get ready for some epic  shirt ripping boom your naps like a  superhero baby  you